magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman we have
some what i would consider potentially
good news coming in the ukraine russia
situation now in this particular case
what we consider good news really
depends on one's perspective in the
entire uh conflict and as many of you
know uh at odds with what
some people believe
both people in my audience and other
people who comment on uh what's going on
uh around the world
i do not see
ukraine as the aggressor i do not see
the responsibility of solving the
conflict to be joe biden's i don't see
the possibility of ukraine joining nato
as a legitimate quote aggression on the
basis of which vladimir putin
could
mass troops at the border threaten
aggression and if it came to it
actually execute aggression uh into
ukraine that's not my perspective i see
that the aggressor massing the troops
is the aggressor and to me that's
calling things what they are now i know
many of you have emailed me and he said
well no you know promises were made that
uh
nato wouldn't expand and it would no
that that that is a false notion and we
went through that yesterday
um
and uh in the context of calling things
what they are there are now some
statements being made uh by russian
authorities which if true if true signal
that this is not going to lead to an
invasion of ukraine which i consider a
good thing
cnn reporting russia announced that some
of its troops would return to base after
completing recent drills but stressed
that major military exercises would
continue ukraine has responded
understandably skeptically saying we'll
believe it when we see it following the
announcement the u.s ambassador to nato
said the u.s will have to verify claims
of a potential move towards
de-escalation by russia meanwhile
last-ditch western diplomatic efforts
continue with german chancellor olaf
schultz in moscow to meet russian
president vladimir putin late monday the
kremlin told cnn putin is willing to
negotiate saying the ukraine crisis was
only one part of russia's larger
security concerns now it can't be
ignored that part of the security
concerns being claimed by russia strike
me as very insincere
uh because when you consider the the
broad claim
that um
uh nato involvement in ukraine is a
direct threat to russia and signals
further this that or the other thing uh
the truth is that there have been other
countries in the area including latvia
where there has been no such escalation
there has been a presence a western
presence and there has been no such
escalation and so it's sort of a an
alleged slippery slope without really a
reason to believe that that's going to
happen but listen i mean if if it's if
putin is genuine that he's willing to
negotiate and and back down i i think
it's a good thing and of course the
question with putin always is
is this 4d chess you know with with
trump uh we would say well when he when
he drew the
using a sharpie on the hurricane map or
when he had that insane call with
ukraine or when he was flushing
documents down the toilet you know there
was this idea it's 4d chess with trump
he's got something planned and very
carefully crafted no he didn't he was a
buffoon there was no 40 chests being
played played things were what they
appeared to be
putin is much smarter than trump it's
just the reality and so with putin there
is the consideration as to is this 40
chess and from the beginning there was
the question of is putin's real
intention to invade or not and if not
what is the underlying intention here uh
the associated press also reporting
russia ready to discuss
confidence-building measures
and that article reads russian president
putin said tuesday moscow is ready for
talks with the u.s and nato on limits
for missile deployments and military
transparency in a new sign of easing
east-west tensions the statement came
after russia announced it is pulling
back some troops from exercises that
raised fears of a potential invasion of
ukraine you know the other thing i i
have a problem with in this entire um
context
are
if you've been watching my show for some
time
um you are i'm sure aware
that when someone like me
says hey
this thing russia's doing isn't good
hey this thing china's doing isn't good
this thing venezuela is doing isn't good
there is a contingent of the left that
hears that and says david
you imperialist bastard
looking to send troops ever i don't know
why i do the alex jones voice but saying
you you want the us troops involved
everywhere and you want biden to send it
no i don't
no i don't that that's not at all what i
want and in fact there's really no
incentive as many of you know
i want stability
i want calm
even if it's out of selfish
desires
for
a steady economy
a calm and tranquil stock market part of
the insanity with three consecutive big
days of market declines etc part of it
has been
the threat of escalation in ukraine
russia why why would i want that i don't
so not not only is it not and i'm
speaking now not just about myself but
others on the left who point out hey we
can agree that putin is the one
threatening aggression here
while still not wanting this to escalate
and not wanting american troops involved
and we we can walk and chew gum at the
same time and immediately as of right
now this might change but the stock
market is reacting very favorably to
what seemed to be decreased tensions in
the region so there is no political
reason that i would want american
imperialism and sending troops or an
escalation i don't want it and even if
you ignore the fact that it doesn't
align with my politics which have been
defaulting to non-intervention in most
cases for for the united states both
politically and militarily and that
applies to cuba venezuela russia etc uh
an unfettered record of such positions
um just out of selfish economic concerns
i would also not be incentivized to want
those things so
that is my perspective on this
and those who continue to try to
attribute
some kind of bloodthirsty hegemonic
imperialism to me
um it's it's just not based in anything
i've ever said i think that's the
important thing let's see what happens
in the next 24 hours
this next story is absolutely
fascinating
many of you might remember the name
sydney powell
sydney powell is this kooky lawyer
who was you know she was working with
trump on the election fraud claims and
then when she got too cartoonish she was
no longer working with trump per the
white house
but then she was seen at the white house
and she filed a bunch of these bogus uh
court uh
legal complaints all of which were
thrown out
she is now admitting
maybe all that stuff she was saying
about the election was not true now i
think we really have to approach this
with a skeptical eye maybe even a
cynical perspective
has she really changed her mind or is
she saying this because she is now in
such jeopardy
because of the things that she did
there's a very interesting vice news
article titled sydney powell finally
admits that perhaps the kraken is not
real
but it also says facing disbarment and
several billion dollar lawsuits the
pro-trump lawyer is kind of changing her
story and i think we have to consider
uh the context here the admission from
powell came in a brief filed monday to
the u.s court of appeal for the sixth
district it was signed by powell and
fellow lawyer howard kleinhendler filed
on behalf of several other kraken
lawyers though notably not pro-trump
lawyer lynn wood who's also a party
back in august you might remember and we
covered this at the time district court
judge linda parker eviscerated powell
and her uh uh team
saying the lawsuit represents a historic
and profound abuse of the judicial
process and it does it's one thing to
take on the charge of vindicating rights
associated with an allegedly fraudulent
election it is another to take on the
charge of deceiving a federal court and
the american people into believing
rights were infringed without regard to
whether any laws or rights were in fact
violated and that is what happened here
now um
powell this is fascinating powell has
argued at the time
she was under no obligation to
thoroughly research the claims that she
made about voter fraud in the lawsuit
she sort of made the case at the time
listen people came to me and they said
this is what happened and it's not up to
me
to independently verify that that's what
the case is i'm just the lawyer here
which the judge does not agree with and
it makes absolutely no sense um
in this week's filing powell and
kleinhandler casually admit
everything they had been saying may not
actually be true
but because lots of people were saying
it at the time they decided to include
it quote millions of americans believe
the central contentions of the complaint
to be true and perhaps they are
admitting she's no longer actually
confident
about the veracity of those claims now
i think it's important to ask the
question
does she believe all of these wacky
election claims are true but she's
backing off because of the legal
problems that she's now happening she's
now having
did she never believe the claims were
true or did she believe them and she has
since changed her mind
legally speaking i don't know that it
makes a difference
um as a reminder here are some of the
wacky things that this woman said
the amount of evidence that this
election was completely fraudulent and
that joe biden is a fraudulent president
is beyond overwhelming now understand
that
if we are to believe her current
statement
what she meant when she said that was
the people i'm working with told me this
but i don't really know it to be true
that's what she now says listen we were
told these things we didn't
independently confirm them here's
another sydney powell clip so
i don't know where to go next because
this is like something out of a movie so
the department of defense let's review
2006 a patent coming from the department
of defense that allows for algorithm
that can flip and change votes
the patent was transferred to i love the
reference to an algorithm
it's an algorithm
it can predetermine that algorithm can
predetermine the outcome of an election
it's specifically to
create a predetermined outcome okay so
maybe she believed that to be true at
the time or again maybe that's just what
some of the people she was working with
told her um here's another one about a
secret server what i think really has to
be
discovered is that there is a secret
server that all the votes go to where
they manipulate the heck out of it now
did she believe that at the time or was
that also just something people were
telling her and here's one last one with
this wacky guy stu peters
that for at least 20 years now
somebody other than the voters of the
united states of america has been
determining
certain elections and this year if not
prior years it happened to be the
presidency of the united states of
america now did she believe that at the
time
or again was it just we were told that
stuff and we didn't investigate it so
sydney powell now saying eh we don't
really know that any of that stuff was
true it's just what we were told just
what we were told by plaintiffs uh she's
really uh potentially in trouble here
and i think that's all that's going on
let me know your thoughts find me on
twitter at d pacman
it is a brand new year maybe you have
goals around getting in better shape
maybe cutting back on sugar
that's why you should check out our long
time sponsor magic spoon magic spoon
tastes exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite
magic spoon lets you enjoy a sweet
delicious snack without the guilt you
can stick to your goals and still treat
yourself and if you don't love magic
spoon as much as i do they'll give you
all of your money back no questions
asked magic spoon is giving my audience
five dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman the
david pakman show depends on the support
of listeners and viewers like you we
have a membership program at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members and you can use the
coupon code wow 22 to save big off of
the price of a membership at
joinpackman.com uh there is a very
rapidly
um uh cons growing in concern movement
among the republican party
about how to get control of the party
back in advance of the 22 midterms and
certainly in advance of the 2024
republican presidential primary now you
might be saying well get control back
from who
uh or you might understand that the
question is about getting control back
from donald trump and there are a number
of interesting articles about this that
have come out over the last 24 hours one
such article in the washington post
reports about clashes between republican
leaders and the candidates that trump
has embraced and that these clashes have
been playing uh playing out around the
country
a chaotic sign that trump's once
unchallenged hold on the party and rank
and file supporters is waning even by
degrees and i think at this point we
have to say
trump's control over the party is waning
but only to a degree in other words we
see that the number of republicans the
percentage of republicans that want
trump to run again is lower but it's
still not low it's still above 50
percent of republicans at last check but
interestingly the washington post writes
the former president's power within the
party and his continued focus on
personal grievances is increasingly
being questioned behind closed doors at
republican gatherings according to
interviews with more than a dozen
prominent republicans in washington and
across the country including some trump
advisers not surprisingly many spoke on
the condition of anonymity
because there remains significant fear
of attracting trump's public wrath also
being reported by business insider on
the basis of the washington post report
republican leaders are holding
closed-door meetings to question trump's
power over the party report says now i
think it's an important
reminder to to tell you guys
questioning trump's power is very
different than questioning trump's uh
questioning trump-ism or the sweeping
authoritarian slide that the republican
party experienced under trump but we'll
get to that in a moment a discontent
with trump is growing among some
republican leaders senior republicans
are questioning trump's hold over the
party in meetings some republicans
reportedly think trump's fixation with
election fraud could cost them in
elections i think the same thing and i'm
hoping that it happens
um and uh i think that the there's a
there's a few different things to talk
about here first of all it's sort of
like six years too late in the sense
that we would be living living not in a
different country
but on a different planet had
republicans had these meetings
previously now they kind of did have
these meetings early on in the
republican primary
and ultimately their voters chose trump
anyway now could the republican party
have done more to prevent trump from
having become the nominee in 2016 yes
they could have done more but it's
possible that because you know the the
issue with the republican electorate is
that it's a monster of their own
creation uh they attacked education for
decades
they abandoned issues increasingly and
focused on cultural issues and talking
points and and this sort of thing
and what that led to in 2016 was a
monster that they couldn't even control
could they have turned the the ship
around
uh once it was summer of 2016 i i don't
know i don't know if they could have the
um the other you know at the same time
the the the best time to plant a tree is
20 years ago the second best time is
today if the republican party is
deciding it wants out of trump
uh okay they didn't do it six years ago
but they can start doing it now
the bigger issue here
is that
even if it's not in their best interests
to have trump represent the party
publicly
it doesn't mean that they want to
abandon the authoritarian non-thinking
reactionary slide that the party
experienced under donald trump they're
not questioning trump's authoritarianism
they're not questioning trump's disdain
for media uh and a free press they're
not they're not questioning any of that
the meetings are about is it good for
the face of the party to be trump doing
rallies complaining about the election
he lost 15 months ago it's about
the particular
person that is out there speaking
um prominently as the face of the
republican party and in fact i i would
say the opposite
they've become enamored over the last
six years
with this kind of hair-brained brand of
authoritarianism
and it's evident in that so many of them
are now stop talking about ron desantis
and falling in line behind desantis
desantis is just as authoritarian as
trump he's more competent than trump
which could make him potentially more
dangerous and effective as well so this
is not a republican um uh
sort of um
reaction
saying we've we've got to get away from
this authoritarianism and get back to
issues they're not saying that at all
um they're not saying wow we've really
tried to end
even the facade of democracy over the
last couple of they're all about all of
that stuff
they are just worried that trump at the
helm
is not best for them from a strategic
point of view they may be right about
that
but uh they don't seem to be concerned
with the actual direction of the party
they just want someone else at the head
of the party so
what effect will this have in november
of 2022 we just don't know yet and
donald trump at this point
i don't think has more rallies scheduled
but there's been talk about will he go
to colorado in support of lauren
beaubert one of the most
weaponized and dangerous
um results of trumpism in the house of
representatives
what is donald trump going to be doing
uh in general between now and the
november election we we will talk a
little bit later about one particular
thing that he's doing which is backing
big lie supporters
in positions of election administration
which is exactly what he said he would
do and he's doing it we're going to get
back to that but it could be a very
interesting matchup here between
anti-trump republicans and trump going
into the midterms what can we hope for
as people on the left let's hope it just
messes them up
and uh limits the degree to which
republicans win in november if at all
and of course we're going to try to work
on the if at all peace and avoid losing
the house and senate but remains to be
seen
this is a very interesting kind of final
point on the sarah palin defamation
lawsuit if you haven't been following
the story
good for you i mean quite frankly good
for you former vice presidential
candidate sarah palin who was uh john
mccain's vice presidential running mate
in 2008 sort of like a precur she was
trump before trump
just cartoony ignorance
and um she sued the new york times she
filed a defamation lawsuit against the
new york times in which she said the new
york times defamed her
by linking her politics and her rhetoric
with real world shootings and sarah
palin sued arguing that it was
defamation now the trial was delayed you
might remember because sarah palin
caught coved
then she was spotted eating out at
restaurants in new york city while
coveted positive i mean just a gross
vile woman but the big news is that a
judge has thrown
the lawsuit out
and somehow fox news is still calling it
a victory and i'm going to show you that
in a little bit cnn reporting
judge jed raykoff the judge overseeing
sarah palin's defamation suit
said monday he will dismiss the suit
ruling palin's team did not prove a key
element of the case rakoff's ruling came
while the jury was already deliberating
rakoff said he will allow the jury to
continue deliberating and to reach a
verdict and then we'll dismiss the case
rakoff presented his findings a very
clear win for the new york times with an
eye towards an inevitable appeals
process the judge said palin did not
prove actual malice which is the
standard her legal team had to meet in a
defamation case this goes back to the
1964 case new york times v sullivan
which specifies if you're a public
figure and you sue for defamation you
have to prove that the offender knew the
claim was false or showed reckless
disregard for the truth the time said
all along it made an error involving
palin they issued a correction but palin
argued the publication smeared her on
purpose seemed like a big uphill battle
to prove that and rakoff has now sided
with the times and said palin's camp did
not present a legally sufficient
evidentiary basis calling it unfortunate
editorializing so
this is being dismissed this is a loss
for sarah palin fox news which operates
in opposite world
is calling it a win here's martha
mccallum breaking news interviewing um
uh howard kurtz and howard kurt says
well it sort of is a win though i mean
take a listen to this pardon me
oh howie don't don't go away i've got
another question for you because we
actually are just covering something
that is breaking moments ago and i i
mentioned this to janine pirro and her
jaw dropped the judge has thrown out
sarah palin's case yeah judge jeanine
pirro was just shocked at the judge's
decision
against the new york times which was
saying that they had defamed her by
suggesting that her pack had something
to do with the shooting and killing of
six people including the injuring of
gabby giffords what's your reaction to
this news well first of all i think that
sarah palin won this case in the court
of public opinion in that a lot of uh no
she didn't what are you talking about
howie very damaging material to the new
york times came out about this editorial
accusing her of political incitement in
a mass shooting in arizona six years
earlier and has not made the new york
times look good but it has always been
the case that it would be very difficult
for the former governor to win this suit
because she's a public figure and
there's a supreme court standard about
having to prove malice or reckless
disregard what i don't completely
understand i love how in this case they
act as if the law as written is like a
technicality that's just inconvenient
for sarah palin even though like her
claims are completely true
the this is all the time they say this
is the law this is the standard we
respect the law and he's saying yeah
based on the law it's not defamation but
he's acting like it's some kind of
unfair technicality but really sarah
palin won and because this is just
breaking is why the judge would send the
case to the jury then say well she
hasn't proven the case as a matter of
law and apparently according to what
we've been told from the courthouse
allowing the jury to continue to
deliberate but the judge has made this
ruling uh that means barring an appeal
uh at least this phase of the case is
over for sarah palin but man i think
that she uh did a lot to shine a light
on the internal processes of the new
york times and it has been pretty ugly
she she really didn't actually and it is
just you know understand
the people that are getting their news
from this
they're hearing sarah palin was right
and she basically won but the judge did
something weird and so like i guess no
the new york times isn't going to have
to pay but she basically won that's not
what happened the case was dismissed the
case is being dismissed you got some of
the folks from the new york times to
admit that they had made mistakes to
apologize for you know presenting things
that were not as they appear you know
differently than the
than the underlying facts even that's
not really true because the new york
times had already issued a correction
like every aspect of this is just not
true but you have to remember
who is the audience here the audience
believes now
sarah palin basically won the case i
mean okay legally she didn't and that's
the only case there is but she basically
won the case this is how fox news works
and you have to remember this is the
hard news hour
of fox news but what's being mentioned
here is just opinion and it happens to
be opinion that doesn't make any sense
if you're just listening to the podcast
today we'll have the clip from fox that
i played on our instagram which you can
find at david pakman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
one of the things we've learned
if we've learned anything over the last
few years is that
when they say they're going to do
something
we should assume that they're telling
the truth
and a great example of this is in the
lead-up to the 2020 election
all of the talk about the ballots can't
be trusted the absentee ballots can't be
trusted vote by mail it's all a scam
it's all corrupt it's all lending itself
to fraud
they were telling us what they were
going to say after the election and at 2
a.m 2 15 a.m eastern time whatever it
was on the night of the 2020 election
trump came out and said he won and then
immediately started casting doubt into
the
absentee ballots and we know what the
story is they're still telling that lie
and roughly half of republicans have
been convinced of that and so when a
couple of months ago donald trump told
us
we are going to be supporting
the right people to run the elections in
2022 and 2024 and i told you
they're telling us what they're going to
do
they're putting people in place so that
instead of you know brad raffensberger
in florida i mean sorry in georgia who
said i'm not going to find you the 11
000 votes you need because you didn't
win not going along with it instead of a
brad raffensberger they'll have someone
who's compliant and someone who's going
to go with it and that is exactly what
is starting up right now the guardian
reports alarm as trump backs big lie
candidates for key election posts in
michigan
it's almost a non-story in the sense
that
they said they were going to do it it
was obvious they were going to do it and
now they're doing it
a trumpus takeover of the battleground
state is raising eyebrows over concerns
of the end of free and fair elections
remember this was trump
um just about a month ago it'd be a lot
sharper the next time when it comes to
counting the vote there's a famous
statement sometimes the
vote counter is more important than the
candidate and we can't let that ever
ever happen again they have to get
tougher and smarter so he told us that
they were going to do it
and they are doing it trump and his
allies are backing numerous candidates
in the coming midterm elections across
the u.s
including in other
vital states like arizona and georgia
but his intervention in michigan raises
particular eyebrows due to its role in
helping trump to win 2016 before
flipping back to democrats in 2020.
the former u.s president and his close
ally mike lindell the mike pillow i'm
sorry the my pillow ceo
are giving strong backing to a michigan
lawyer and key promoter of debunked
election fraud charges who is seeking
the republican nod to be the state's
next attorney general
trump plans to hold a fundraiser for
matthew diperno on march 8th at his
florida mar-a-lago club where lindell
told the guardian he will speak to boost
diperno's chances to be the republican
to take on the democratic attorney
general dana nessel christina caramo a
community college professor who also
peddled conspiracy theories about
election fraud and who has never held
elected office has received trump's
backing to be the republican secretary
of state candidate to challenge
incumbent democrat jocelyn benson in the
fall elections
these positions matter for 2024's vote
count
as the guardian points out the secretary
of state plays a crucial role in
overseeing elections trump loyalists are
investing heavily to capture several of
these posts this year and early this
month trump spoke at a fundraiser at
mar-a-lago for the gubernatorial
campaign
of conservative commentator and
businesswoman tudor dixon who has backed
a vaguely defined forensic audit
remember they we never really know what
it means to do a forensic audit um it
sounds oh so you want to review the
ballots and then trump goes no well the
ballots are the problem we got to go
deeper
well what what are you talking about
um trump called dixon very special he's
not yet made an official endorsement
she's one of 12 republicans who want to
be the next
uh governor
this is exactly what they have planned
for 2024
and um
this is one of the major reasons why
donald trump will be involved in 2022
he's saying it out loud we don't yet
know whether he's going to run in 2024
but no matter whether trump does or
doesn't run they are going to try again
and we know the techniques we know all
of the techniques at this point and as
i've said before
one of the problems when you're playing
defense against such aggressive horrible
people who are willing to do anything
at the end of the day they're willing to
do anything
is
they only need to be slightly more
prepared than you
on one of these areas right you've got
voter fraud claims and dozens of
lawsuits and criminal court complaints
the possibility of
getting a vice president to try to send
things back to the states
trying to get states to send alternate
slates of electors they have all these
different techniques a state of
emergency idea and you've got to play
defense on all of them and if you're not
there on every single one of those
methods
it's conceivable that they could get
away with it it's hopefully still not
likely but it's conceivable and remember
if the military had been with him
in 2020
could the coup have worked we don't know
but former uh retired rather military
generals have said
you've got to be really careful about
that because we believe it could have
been
a possibility that trump might have had
a better shot at staying in power if the
military brass supported him fortunately
they didn't
if raffensberger had been willing in
georgia
could it maybe have worked could it
maybe have given him georgia and then
justified who knows what else in other
states i don't know
but there is no doubt about where this
is heading and it is very scary and you
know when we read the
piece from the canadian political
scientist i believe his name is thomas
homer dixon saying the u.s could be a
dictatorship by 2030. when we read about
all these things i understand just like
for you
i am both desensitized because of the
insanity of the last six years
and some part of me doesn't really want
to believe that something like that
could happen
but the right is doing everything that
they can and everything they can think
of
to give themselves the possibility of
just choosing who becomes president
regardless of who gets the most votes
and so
ignore this stuff at our own peril i
think is the cautionary tale that we
must remember
a bunch of you sent me um articles about
this next story
and it shouldn't come as a surprise but
it should be extraordinarily alarming
because of what it means
the accounting firm which has
represented trump's business for a
decade
is now saying
we can't trust you can't trust i me
david pakman i can't trust
the
financial accounting records
that they put together for the last
decade
because they may be based on underlying
fraudulent information
and the accounting firm has abandoned
trump and says they will no longer
represent trump's business this is
unbelievable
yahoo news nbc news reporting trump
organizations accounting firms
says accounting firm says it can no
longer vouch for financial statements
from the company
this is a major story and it is not
getting the attention it deserves the
accounting firm mazars usa
said a decade's worth of financial
statements from the trump organization
can no longer be viewed as reliable
according to a letter made public monday
by new york attorney general leticia
james as part of her civil probe into
trump's company
mazars also said it will no longer work
with the trump organization meaning the
company may have to get new financial
statements that could complicate its
ability to secure loans in a february 9
letter from mazar's group general
counsel william kelly to the trump
organization's chief legal officer the
auditing firm said its work from 2011 to
2020 quote should not be relied upon
in the world of corporate accounting
this is like a groundbreaking statement
of
there's some really bad stuff going on
here and we meaning the accounting firm
want to try to get the hell out from
under what might be coming in our
direction
uh they also added we right to advise
that the statements of financial
condition for donald j trump for the
years ending june 30th 2011
to june 30th 2020 that's fiscal years
should no longer be relied upon and you
should inform any recipients thereof
currently relying upon one or more of
those documents that those documents
should not be relied upon understand
that that is a signal to all of the
lenders that have given trump money on
the basis of these financial statements
they
they're being told you made financial
decisions about the trump organization's
credit worthiness
on the basis of account of account
accounting documents that we the
accounting firm are telling you cannot
be relied upon uh here's a copy of the
letter
sent out
uh dear alan this is to alan garton the
um
chief legal officer of the trump
organization this and from the
accounting group dear alan it's like a
dear john letter we write to advise that
the statement a financial condition for
donald j trump from 2011 to 2020 should
no longer be relied upon and you should
inform recipients relying on those not
to
we have come to this conclusion this is
the best part we have come to this
conclusion based in part upon the
filings made by the new york attorney
general on january 18 2022
our own investigation and information
received from internal and external
sources they are saying in part
the investigation being carried out by
leticia james of new york
has brought to their attention
the
corruption
and
alleged fraud potential fraud i want to
be careful with how i say that
committed by the trump organization and
we already know what this relates to
this mostly seems to relate to the
valuation of assets
what michael cohen and others have told
us the trump organization would
regularly do
is you take a building let's say we
agree that in the real world the
building is worth 20 million dollars
when it comes to assessment for tax
purposes
the trump organization would say look at
this crappy building it's not worth 20
million it's worth 10 million dollars so
tax us
on the 10 million dollar valuation and
they would submit documents supporting
that that's what it's worth on the other
hand when the trump organization wanted
to get a loan using that same building
as collateral they would say listen
this building's not worth 10 million
this building's not worth 20 million
this building's worth 40 million dollars
and so you can give us you know if it's
an 80 loan to value or whatever the case
is you can give us a loan
on the basis that the collateral we're
offering you is worth 30 or 40 million
dollars rather than 20. and that would
encourage a lender to say
we can give them 28 million bucks
because if they default we take the
building and we sell the building for 30
or 40. when the building is only worth
10 or 20
giving a 28 million dollar loan with
that building as collateral obviously is
not a good idea for the lender so that's
the gist of what has been done
um other notes from the letter
um
due in part to our decision regarding
the financial statements as well as the
totality of the circumstances uh we have
reached the point such that there is a
non-waivable conflict of interest with
the trump organization as a result we
are not able to provide any new work
product
to the trump organization
um
this is an example
of rats abandoning
a sinking ship
and it's crimes all the way down
and consider
that
trump was elected partially on the basis
that he was a really successful
entrepreneur
and then we found out well he's had a
bunch of business bankruptcies but he
said that was him just using the tax
code to his advantage
this additional thing suggests that even
the degree to which his business was
successful
was based upon accounting distortions or
at least potentially on that basis and
when i hear you can't trust these uh
accounting documents and we're not
working for you anymore what i hear is
we committed fraud for the boss
and we're gonna get caught and we're
doing what we can to wash our hands of
him and i think
anybody who knows anything about trump
knows that cutting corners is sort of
the name of the game it's the status quo
and people continue to love the guy and
defend the guy but this is not looking
good at all in terms of this
investigation into the trump
organization will it ever hit trump i
still don't think so
and i know many of you get mad when i
say that but i don't think so let me
know if you have a different view on
that particular piece
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show let's
start now with some of the kind of last
gasps of obvious 2020 election delusion
i'm going to talk to you about the term
decertification now some of you will
already know where this is going um
in the united states
once states
certify
an election
there is no legal provision to then
decertify that election
and even if a state
figured out some way to decertify an
election if arizona now said hey we're
decertifying our election from november
of 2022
it still wouldn't remove the sitting
president of the united states you'd
need to remove the sitting president you
know either through invoking the 25th
amendment and the process that goes
there or uh through impeachment and even
if you did that the vice president would
assume the position
so there is no such thing as
decertification
in the way that some people have been
claiming it exists
my pillow ceo mike lindell
known to us as mike pillow
he is still talking about election
decertification and in fact he appeared
yesterday on the stephen bannon show
called the war room uh stephen bannon is
a former trump advisor former breitbart
propagandist and he has been hosting
pillow for a while now
and pillow's new thing is he now has
elected officials
supporting
multiple decertifications it's happening
imminently guys imminently this is going
to happen take a look at this and ask
yourself the question
does pillow believe this
or is he just giving fodder to the last
people that still believe this stuff
well arizona you know that was a god
what about over a week ago now they uh
they've got quite a few representatives
and um uh senators that signed on we're
getting more and more every day i was in
wisconsin and
all they need there we i was over there
with a great tim rampant a uh he is the
senator that put the bill before to
uh has it ready to decertify wisconsin
no he doesn't pillow it was an amazing
event i was there five hours i planned
on being there for a half hour but there
was wisconsin there all over wisconsin
but the lies were so compelling he
stayed five hours so go hey we have the
evidence let's get this de-certified i
met some other senators and
representatives steve they're they're
this close to getting on board they all
i believe we can get them all to jump on
together because a lot of them still
live in fear they're going you know fear
or they're not they were very
very um a lot of ed kids just to be
educated on this that a lot of them said
well there's nothing that can be done
anyway absolutely there can be done that
we've got lawyers constitutional lawyers
look at this three of these states you
you decertify and then it goes back to
all the states and uh and it votes one
person or one state one vote and there's
it's republican control that is a
complete and total lie i mean understand
that this is not aside from whether
there's the willingness to do this aside
from whether there's the interest of
doing this aside from whether there's
any empirical evidentiary support for do
put all of that aside
even if it happened it doesn't go back
to where each state gets to cast one
vote about who becomes president of the
united states it's just it's a fantasy
so this is very real and it's come it's
manifesting no it's coming to fruition
and it's going to happen steve now
understand that pillow has made an
entire sequence of predictions in
november of 2020 he said by december it
would be flipped to trump in december he
said that in time for january 6th it
would be flipped to trump on january 7th
or 8th he said by the time of the
inauguration it will be flipped to trump
after that he said march april then it
got pushed to the summer then the end of
summer then in august he said it would
be by october and then he said it's
going to be by thanksgiving and then
it's going to be by the end of the year
and
it's 2022 guys and it's not happening
now
we are
almost at the next election we're almost
at the midterms
everything that he says in this clip
about what could happen and how things
would happen is a lie
i don't know whether pillow even
believes this stuff i highly doubt
bannon believes this stuff and the idea
here is wisconsin
and arizona will decertify
the winds of joe biden
15 16 months ago
now to take it seriously for a second
this has been studied
there is no legal basis to decertify
a u.s presidential election there is no
provision in the constitution to
decertify a presidential election to
remove a sitting president you need
they die okay then goes to the vp
um you have a the invocation of the 25th
amendment
if a president is unable to discharge
the powers of office you have a
conviction on impeachment you have a
resignation okay in all of these
situations the vice president becomes
the president you don't go
to a candidate who lost 15 months ago
constitutional experts have talked about
we've now talked about the electoral
count act many times
and it provides the process for
certifying the presidential election it
doesn't have a provision for
decertification and it's almost like
these guys like pillow and others think
anything any process that exists can be
run in reverse it's almost like hitting
a rewind button on a vcr
um it's not true
and even if a state were to undo its
certification
it would have no legal significance
whatsoever so these these people are in
a fantasy world i don't know whether
they believe it maybe you have some kind
of sense all right i want to go through
something that's just it's so crass and
it's so
um
emblematic i guess i would say
of the
kind of vapid and and coarse nature of
the modern republican party um radical
republic if you say to me david sir
who were the three sort of most
cartoonish clowns in the house of
representatives right now i would say
well it's marjorie taylor green
um it's madison cawthorne and it's
lauren bober and then after that there's
a lot of candidates you know could be
matt gates louis gomer very very long
list but certainly in the top three as i
hit my microphone here and
uh almost almost damage it um lauren
beaubert would certainly be in the top
three lauren beaubert has been given
the hottest woman in congress award
by one of these right-wing channels
and the award misspelled her name
and included a gift card
to
to red lobster
um to the to the seafood chain red
lobster
if you were to satirize
the modern republican party on a show
like saturday night live
you would create a hottest woman in
congress award
misspell the recipient's name and
include a gift card to like arby's or
red lobster or something like that it's
exactly what you would do um let's let's
take a look at this um
if you look at her holding the award
uh you see that her
name had been spelled lauren bo bart
with an a b-a-r-t
and then sort of corrected honestly it
looks like a sharpie to be lauren beau
bert with an e or bo bear as uh
congressman ro connor referred to her
and there's a gift card in there and
that gift card is to red lobster and
it's in the amount of 27.43
which i guess the point there is you as
a member of congress you you violate
some ethics laws if you accept a gift
worth more than 50
so i guess that's how they came up with
uh
27.43
here is her being told by jesse kelly
who knows who these people are about the
award joining me now the first winner of
the jesse kelly show hottest woman in
congress list congresswoman from
colorado lauren beaubert congresswoman
first and foremost before we get to all
the news of the day i want to
congratulate you on such a high
achievement and hope you got ours to i
see you did get our certificate and i
want to make sure you also got the gift
card we sent along with it
i got it
look at that jesse how's that
and
jesse i do think that 2743
is under the gift limits um but if we
check with ethics and it's over this is
coming right back to you
yes ma'am i understand that we're gonna
do the best we can to up that to 30 next
year depending on how the show does but
moving forward
the second hottest woman in congress she
was the runner-up this year aoc went on
twitter
and whined once again like she always
yeah
um
you know trump's flushing documents down
the toilet
beau bert is getting misspelled hottest
woman in congress award
if this is a simulation
someone has a very interesting sense of
humor and i think the the important
thing here is i keep going back you know
we talk about how do we engage with
these people how do you how do you talk
sense into folks who
believe the things that people like
lauren beaubert and marjorie taylor
green and others say is it just a matter
of having a few conversations with them
or whatever
i never want to say that people
generally speaking are too far gone
but you have to understand that there's
sort of like a culture of ignorance
and um
anti-intellectualism
and a sort of pride in lacking any
sophistication or depth in one's
thinking
and you know lauren bobert getting the
hottest woman award and it's been
misspelled it's it's not
the be-all end-all of reminding us about
that reality right now among this
right-wing american political movement
and the fact that this is how how
unsophisticated and anti-intellectual
they are
but it's just a reminder that
this movement is so pervasive and i'm
reminded of this you know when
whenever i go to a conservative state
and all of a sudden i'm in the middle of
you know some fair or whatever the case
may be i'm reminded there there's nobody
who could come here and just talk sense
into these people in any real way and
that's what gets us to
we just have to get voter turnout up we
have to just overwhelm them with numbers
because most of them are not going to be
convinced we've got to fix education so
we prevent people from becoming this
uninformed in the first place it is a
colossal task that we are faced with in
this country and this is just a little
microcosm of that that really epitomizes
how you can't distinguish between how
these right wingers would be satirized
on skit and comedy programs and what
they actually are there's essentially no
daylight uh between those two those two
things anymore
we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to david p
here's a caller who always leaves very
trollish questions
but there's actually some meaty sort of
substance here to talk about let's play
it and then we'll discuss
a real question with real substance
please
should big pharma
pay for the education of doctors
since all of their doctors basically
push their pharmaceuticals right
i don't see them pushing
vitamins minerals nutrition
good food healthy food unprocessed foods
ultra processed foods
all that stuff is bad for you
but they push pharmaceuticals
please answer that question okay so the
caller is sort of confused now what i i
am i have to assume that what the caller
means by should pharmaceutical companies
be allowed to educate doctors i assume
what they mean is that pharmaceutical
companies send their own reps to tell
doctors about medications and how they
work and it is sales it is essentially
saying to doctors here's a great
medication for conditions prescribe this
i assume that that's what the caller is
talking about and that entire
infrastructure is very problematic in
the united states we also have in the
united believe it's the u.s and
new zealand
i think
the only two countries where you can
directly market medications to consumers
through media like you you see ads on tv
ask your doctor about this medication or
that medication that's a major problem
now that being said
um i think
there are more and more doctors who are
talking generally speaking about the
importance of a good and healthy diet
understanding uh just basics about
nutrition
undoing bad or flawed ideas i you know i
know
many doctors in many specialties who
talk to me about they try to have
conversations with patients that are
much more general about lifestyle um and
so i i don't think it's fair to say that
doctors aren't doing that i do think
that unfortunately particularly when you
look at specialists
specialists tend to be dealing with
um
disease in a way where
you have to use the tools available at
the time and so if someone comes in and
they have you know skin cancer or they
already have diabetes
of course you talk about
lifestyle and you should generally wear
sunscreen when you go out in the sun and
you should eat a healthy diet in order
to improve the the diabetes but you also
have to deal with the situation as it is
and sometimes that includes medication
or surgical interventions or whatever
the case may be but i i don't i don't
find this question to be this guy calls
in and always says i'm a troll and i'm
asking trolling questions
i think there's some confusion in the
caller but i think that there is no
question that doctors are understanding
uh these kind of structural and systemic
factors and the importance of of a
healthy lifestyle and all of that at the
at the tail end of it there's this very
kind of
pernicious thing where
you know
there are conditions
that
are very much lifestyle related
and if everybody did quote what they
were supposed to do
you would almost put some specialists
out of business because all of a sudden
you reduce the number of people with
that condition i get that i get that i
get that a lot of money is made treating
conditions that are
preventable in many cases and that's a
conversation we've also had but it's a
little bit different than what the
caller is asking we have a great bonus
show for you today more and more
democrats are getting anxious
about joe biden just getting the
replacement on the court for stephen
breyer sooner than later
and we're going to talk about that
there is a jewish student who was
reprimanded
for exposing
that students did a nazi salute in class
it wasn't the students doing the salute
who were reprimanded it was the jewish
student who blew the whistle what
we'll talk about that on today's bonus
show and also we're going to talk about
the organic cotton movement
and we will talk about what is what does
organic cotton mean
and we're going to talk about scams
within that movement as well very
disturbing marketing thing that is going
on all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show don't miss it get
instant access by signing up at
joinpackman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
magic spoon tastes exactly like your
favorite childhood breakfast cereals but
it has no sugar lots of protein it's
keto and low carb friendly it's
delicious without the guilt get five
dollars off when you click my link below
and use the promo code pacman